بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد كين ان كتاب
الوجيز في فقه السنه والكتاب العزيز ان ذك
صلاه
صلاه الجمعه
جمعه
صلاه
شهود الجمعه فرض عين على كل مسلم الا خمسه
صلاه الجمعه
types
يقول عبد مملوك
او امراه
او امراه هو لماذا يعني يقول المؤلف عبد
مملوك عبد وهذا من من باب عطف البيان او
هذا يسمى ب صفه بيان هذا من باب زياده
البيان والا فالعبد المفرو المقصود به
العبد
العباده الشرعيه
او العباده
التي هي الرق
يقول عبد مملوك so ذا firstستف او امراه
او صبي
او مريض
او مسافر
where
all
the exact par
‏illos
you are
before that you are have kind any
‏ill with to individual
sitation so if we speaking about fasting
illness that has to do with fasting if
we speaking about illness that impedes
right let say someone
has a limp
a limp this imped them to
‏illing
about
[Silence]
او مسافر
امراه
انثى
because
ج
قال الله تعالى يا ايها الذين امنوا اذا
نودي للصلاه من يوم الجمعه
فاسعوا الى ذكر الله وذروا البيع ذلكم خير
لكم ان كنتم تعلمون
الله
سوره الجمعه
[Silence]
وعن طارق بن شهاب عن النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم قال الجمعه حق واجب على كل مسلم في
جماعه الا اربعه
عبد مملوك او امراه او صبي او مريض
هيز
شهاب
صلى الله عليه وسلم طارقن شهاب
compar
صلى الله عليه وسلم
however
point
because
ag
صلى الله عليه وسلمخمخضم
[Silence]
ion
صلى الله عليه وسلم 40
would
عليه
ان شاء الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الجمعه صلاه الجمعه
الجمعه
جما
عبد مملوك
او امراه
او صبي
او مريض
‏ins
what is
with proping
highest form of ad of
‏when ching our
things if there
about
the ex way that we to add
we make up our own words are the best
thees that we take from the prop
are better said no ‏And so the mine as a
form of respect a form of
admiration
and and exaltation of the prophet
[Arabic recitation]
is that if he spoke about something
that if we can we always use his words
even if we don't say this is a narration
that's been narrated we can just use the
same words
صحيح البخاري
الامام البخاري
صحيح
how
many times before بوكس صحيح البخاري
المسلمون
قران
صحيح البخاري
97ح
البخاري
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه
‏If you look at the chapter tit the
chapter tit are his words as well he
says the chapter of such and such when
he writes chapter titles those are the
rulings that he is the conclusions then
the chapter title is basically the
conclusion he's saying this is the
ruling and then he mentions the
narration to support that ruling so when
he choes the chapter title
صلى الله عليه وسلم يرحمك اللهح
البخاري
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه
صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول وعن ابن عمر عن
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قال ليس على
المسافر جمعه والحديث عند الامام مسلم من
صحيح مسلم ابن عمر
صلى الله عليه وسلم
جمعه
على على في اصول الفقه يفيد الوجوب على
على فلان كذا وكذا لي عليه كذا وكذا هذا
يدل على الوجوب هذا اسلوب ايجاب لكن
لا يفهم من الحديث انه لا تجزئ او لا يحث
المسافر على حضور الجمعه يحث يحث على
الجمعه لكن ليس عليه الجمعه ليس يجب على
المسافر صلاه جمعهد
الامام مسلم رحمه الله نسال الله سبحانه
وتعالى ان يفقهنا في ديننا وان يستعملنا
ولا يستبدلنا قبل موتنا والله اعلم وصلى
الله وسلم على نبينا محبته
حالك ‏Yeah.